hello good afternoon can everybody hear
me in the back yeah okay great sounds
good so I'm on way I've sure been a
company for 16 years and a pleasure
working with Catherine you know for was
specially in the storage space have
spent most of my time I trading the R&D
world just moved to Beijing last year on
to drive this organization 10 so engaged
without developer in our ecosystem are
really creating some new innovations in
terms of application space only platform
you know one of the additional roller
I'm taking on since i moved to Beijing
is really look at a cloud are you
looking at a claw how do we actually
landing cloud in china in greater china
region so it's my great pleasure today
to come in front of this audience and
ever having a dialogue so i hope that i
will have some kind of left towards n
and you know force in active Q&A so
today I'm really going to share a little
bit about Microsoft's cloud strategy and
as the strata solar only as we
experimented using some of the paradigm
shift you know we see and how does that
really impact academic community
especially from a scientific research
perspective so let me get started so
there's a lot of buzz your industry as
we're talking about Klaus we're talking
about what is this definition of cloud
is it just the same if you know hosting
business and as their how different that
is you know compared to the grid
computing or HP CNN so on so forth so
this is some of the things that you know
as we cannot enter into this space
actually Microsoft has being in that
space for a while if you were looking at
the set of a consumer call services that
we have been playing and then some of
the commercial call services wedding
pushing out in the last few years so we
started taking a look at this and really
asking ourselves what is the call
convenient what some of the
characteristics that call company have
demonstrated so here's field versa
you know comments or definitions are
coming from the industry research groups
there's really a few cubes sort of
popping ah I think it's important to
recognize in terms of skeletal in terms
of elasticity in terms of it business
model in terms of pay our pay as you go
and also the requirement in terms of how
do we standardize cetera you know
technologies based on infrastructures to
platforms to the application layers so
this is a set of things that you know
really you know lineman instance or what
Microsoft has been you know
communicating in terms of you know the
call computing in terms of some of the
key characteristics we want to see
building the infrastructure as well as
in the application space now as we sort
of our talking about kind of theory old
acquaintances or what that definition
really is let me kind of quickly going
sue the city of scenarios are you
interning Microsoft would stop talking
like workloads so the question is really
why are we using coal computing ok now
I'm move on the business side as we
started looking at the set of customer
scenario what are the things are
stepping a little bit in terms of
Internet of Things panel yeah you know
Kathleen sort of mentioned it's all
about a customer it's all about what the
customer water in terms of the business
operations they are facing our business
challenge they are facing day in and day
out so here's a letter for you know
distinct sort of workloads that we
typically see okay all right in a for
the first one in terms of aronoff
services this is that something that are
typically happening in the financial you
know business in terms of some of the
financial reporting running and a
forecast a running after days of you
know transactions and in some of the
growing fast business is really kind of
represented especially in the internet
edge if you're looking at some of the
web companies looking at you know social
network companies ecommerce companies
would you see their rapid behavior as
they accumulate customers and a user
base that demand and the stress on the
backend system kind of grow
exponentially and a certainly some of
the things that happens you know due to
this
Astra's or due to potentially even some
of the viral marketing activity you
might actually experienced some
unexpected a peek and instantly they are
scenarios related to regular predictable
business like for instance Christmas
holiday they're going to come about I
was just making a set of a mermaid calls
for my daughter for the whole wing it
was interesting in the Shanghai as you
know cold market that all the vendors
knows that all the foreigners are
Russian in October try to make those
mini dresses for them you know for the
little girls you know at home so as we
sort of encountering those scenarios you
know the things from the IT perspective
home front of business parts or
perspective I keep asking is that how do
I really cool my business more
effectively more efficiently at the most
cost-efficient manner so this is really
a time that we believe as a company that
we're in this critical juncture the new
generation of RT how it's being managed
how it's being planned always being
billed and I was being deployed is going
to be radically different as we're
moving to the next stage it does require
a very scalable elastic systems it does
require set of new business and
operating models that is very different
than our previous of software or into it
you know paradigm so as we look into
those scenarios certainly in the
industry you know we're talking a lot
about in terms of a set of standard
taxonomy to describe on technology
perspective how do we enable those
things so let me sort of go through some
of that Microsoft take a deeper look at
those and then try to provide some
clarity okay so historically I mean
everybody is familiar with this whole
package of software mentality in terms
of I'm bringing operating systems are
pay for licenses and all those things
kind of listener from here in terms of
network up to you know the application
is all managed by the customer it is
customers responsibility to operate
all the new apps being there it is their
responsibility now as those customers in
area described or they are this might
not be the right moderating they're
moving forward so many other things
incidentally where I've seen in a
business is starting as hey how do I
really building a skeletal systems and
then have the vendor to really manage
some of the base infrastructures from
the network's to the virtualization okay
that's sort of typically and industrial
infrastructure as a services a typical
example is if you look at amazon ec2 so
of fall into that category but whenever
things are still required for
application or application or for the
business is that this do you have to
manage an OS this you have to manage
older one x and middle were lawyers you
still have to spend a lot of times in
terms of you know the business logic and
applications so the burden of the
managing the OS is still resides in
application developers you know hand
also the business hand now fill out is
that a notion of a powerful as a
services ok so that's it that's the area
we're basically saying look you know not
only we're going to help you to managing
some of the basic infrastructure we're
going to manage your always we're going
to you know manager runtimes and a
making sure that's a fully scalable we
believe that application developers
focus is really should be on will be no
the best is in that business scenarios
in that you know academic scientific
research scenarios and i really put in
the head around those instead of
worrying about you know backing
infrastructures is one x so that's
actually a direction that assumingly
microsoft aching if you're thinking
about a window as you're you know as a
platform as a service to bring all those
management from and that work to you
know the one tile layer and a really
taken care for you and a really
partnering with the community to really
drive set of a true application
innovation in a new era and it certainly
the sofa is a service in a chewy having
our entire staff
has been being run and being operated in
a bottle vendor so that's sort of a way
that as we look into the industry
defying to tech sauna me and how do we
see all those bits and pieces fit ok now
we talk of the scenarios we're talking
about the characteristic we're talking
about the industry taxonomy so what
exactly you know microsoft is offering
microsoft is doing in those spaces in a
living things that everybody's very
familiar with our traditional or you
know server platform okay so those are
the likes of women syrian superserver in
assistance center and all the
virtualization management stack and in
some of the key thing is that we still
make that available this is a very
critical or two similar business
especially in the traditional software
business as was even in the
infrastructure as a service business we
have seen larger number of holsters for
example and also you know private entity
you want to build a new generation of
data centers using the server technology
using those commoditize the hardware's
and then learn that control one there
customization capabilities so that's our
show something that Microsoft has been
in a working on also providing a set of
solutions for instance dynamic data
center toolkit as well as the
self-service player would it you need of
a set of scenarios are you know for
their our photo customers that even
really importantly we since 2008 have
launched this set of a services
platforms more angle on the windows
azure and also seek washer and that very
profitable has been operating again as I
say in the last couple years we launched
the commercially
end of 2009 so we only be running this
thing for the last you know Lessing a
year the results has been pretty
significant and we have you know more
than 12,000 you know companies actually
running experimenting you know the as
your services and it will continuously
evolving the set of platforms in on a
very rapid pace so you know actually let
me kind of go through a bit more detail
in terms of you know as your profit what
is that so there's really three key
components ok so there's a windows as
your services it is really sort of
scalable computing and storage are you
know services is automatic service
management and a set of familiar tools
and the relative is worth more to court
I'll are in terms of the storage space
there's a you know for the persistent
storage there is a three infrastructure
have been built into Windows a juror in
a form of tables and blobs and also
queues and as we must a favor I mean
we're actually introduced the CEO sure
one of the important thing is that's the
only relational database services that
is available today okay so in addition
to you know unstructured data storage
that we have been providing in Windows
you are one of the things that we feel
is very important to bring that
relational database forward part of
reason is also getting a lot of those
commercial existing commercial
applications smoothly easily transition
from on-premise world to online services
will and outerwear I should make that
development experience you know
continuous and the city that is set of a
zero fabric it's all about how do we get
your commenting existing apps you know
to the cloud and in making sure all
those applications can work seamlessly
across the network boundaries so those
have a new set of clinical services
platform that we're bringing to the
marketplace ticking able new
of call up occasion development and in
addition to that a lot of people should
start worried about as a you know this
is a new set of platforms a little bit
different than Windows Server and sequel
server and system management what does
that mean what does that mean to my
developer in terms of set of skill sets
that already build on the existing
platform so many of the things that and
other companies being a lot of attention
to is driving their continuity so
although this is set of new platform
there's a set of common skill sets so
they persist across on-premise and
online so those are uniform of dinette
technology visual studio as a set of
development tools and a certainly you
know management you know active
directory and etc those are all common
across really the students company also
spent a lot of effort is to recognize
this need the open platform so in
addition to the great support we're
going to have on the dollar languages
there's also a great support in terms of
java and PHP zanden pythons you know
really kind of making that and as open
platform as a possible to encourage the
new generation of call application
development you know to the next level
no men of the things that we always
believed was a Microsoft sort of you
know thought feeding your things okay so
and it's ending it instead of a new
business needs now this is all about
platform as a service now on total
platform is this layer of data so one of
the things today we have a lot of
challenges I mean from the application
developer perspective a very simple
scenario right I want to take my wife
out for a day or in Beijing now usually
what i will do you know all my mobile
phone you know is a set of activities i
will take a looking at you know what's
the best restaurant or you know the area
that I want to you know take my wife to
I want to looking at the restaurant
reviews when looking at some of the
activities potentially around their
neighborhoods away after the dinner I
can take my wife to a show to a you know
20 to a play and also need to figure out
for my home to you know there's
locations how do I you know show the
maps and all that stuff that I can drive
to their place in the shortest distance
or shortest possible time frame a lot of
those data sets are available in god
those are scattering along and then
require me as application developer go
out so they're looking at those things
and try to stitching together if the
application developer want to put
together a composite you know web
applications to support that scenario so
again that's just a very simple you know
for require a lower number of you know
data sets but as you go into the
scientific community if you go into some
of the commercial scenarios it is
actually really important to have a mass
amount of public trusted data or trusted
commercial data available and making
sure that that developer can actively
leverage those you know information at
their fingertips you know creating a new
generation of context-aware and people
where your applications you know was
that you might we actually build a Prada
really sort of a data market place
called Dallas that a completely built on
top of Windows Azure and when is a very
powerful and it really hopes to bring a
lot of those credible public and private
data sets into the bail application
developer you know to generate new set
of applications that it can be used on
any powerful on any devices and also
either some of a business opportunity
for this you know better set owners are
you know so that particular
the same of data British our baggage to
really connecting the actual need enter
the data source and the City on top of
that you know with the installation of
those data sets the set of bi
capabilities in terms of analysis in
terms of reporting you know can be dying
a very seamless are in a very seamless
manner so this is just another you know
example in terms of you know call sort
of bring a new possibilities to not only
the end users but also advanced a lot of
application developers so now we said a
lot of things along are the definitions
and the scenarios and technology and a
whistle home feelings one of the things
is you know a lot of people out of
people are asking us and how do we
operate those how do we operate those
massively distributed you know systems
to enable mass amount of customers to
deal with massive on data sets so this
is answer is something that Microsoft
has been very proud of this is an area
that we're having operating for the last
15 years in terms of our geo-located
data centers & away 3 now we have more
than those six those are the six
particularly used for provide as you are
you know platform services there's two
in a North America to Europe and in
Tunisia the teenager was in Singapore
the other ones in Hong Kong and they're
just giving everybody a sense of scale I
mean those are massively amount of you
know sizes with us and taking our are
the most central of your data center in
the US are you in Chicago this is
actually a su generation data center
that we actually are you know putting
through our container sort of
infrastructure it is in a space of
700,000 or you know square square feet
you know there are about six teams over
football you know stadia size 50
60 containers each container was about
more than 2,000 servers okay it's a
highly you know convinced you know
property was a lot of our computing
powers and what's important there is
that we actually do a lot of things to
enable that some infrastructure managing
this set of infrastructure not only at
the Silver level but also the network
the electricity's and the you know
facilities there's a mass amount of
security you know efforts that are put
into making sure that data is secure and
actually can provide services in a
worldwide so this is type of investment
the company have been putting in the
last 15 years so we're going to
continuously putting a lot of effort to
enable those infrastructures are all are
your application you know to grow into
the next level now one of the things as
you know as I being in China which is
very interesting as to is a unique place
I think a lot of the cloud services sort
of bring new set of challenges are two
locations like China as you might all
know you know besides the technical
challenges the additional set of
challenges that claw brings a really
long operations as well as business
models but even more importantly is the
policies okay now so this is a country
that I like actually many other
countries in Europe and you know why
have a distinct definition or interest
in terms of controlling and monitoring
the data the dais almond tease are as
well as said it with regulations to do
with you know privacy's and etc is
similar very different so when are the
key things that you know as we heard for
our customers as well as the government
saying this is a great this is a lot of
infrastructures but you know what
they're not here they're not in China
they're not in my territory I hope you
know how should I trust you Michael
volved actually holding my customer my
commercial data okay so there's a real
real situation that's a situation is not
unique to China by the way I think know
why they have the similar you know
issues so that's really the things that
you know very excited about are you know
in july this year in washington DC in
the rely upon a conference in microsoft
author really amongst this new line of
capabilities okay as you can see over
here microsomal really running massive
Oliver you know data center networks to
enable windows your and a sequel as your
services you know worldwide and rid of
the things to understand those
regulatory requirement and a policy
requirement Microsoft is actually
offering a new set of scenarios where
you know what how do we actually packing
those things up in partnership with our
hardware vendors and our solution
partners to bring it as appliance to
connecting with our local service
providers already been provide for
instance in China you know think about
the teracles are even thinking about you
know some of the large photos that is
original even thing you know the
government themself are you know in
Beijing we actually however you know a
large claw initiative run by Beijing
government in Shanghai Shanghai just
announced a a three-year called plan are
going to spend five hundred million
dollars in the next three years to build
up infrastructures so thinking about how
do we enable those technologies our
further and local service providers
really bring as your services are to a
mass population and incidentally there's
another scenario in terms of a customer
you know we actually have that scenario
you ebay that's actually one of the you
know partner that we have announced in
july ebay basically say you know what
this is actually great but i want to
manage
my IT and this is actually a great
opportunity you know for me to manage my
IT but I want to manage it by myself I
want to control that stuff can you do
that so many of the things that we
actually upon or is our ebay right
values bring their containing for
sergeant in ebay that data center as a
way to replace the entire IT
infrastructure moving forward so so
those are the things that can be very
exciting to the set of a jew
capabilities post one infrastructure to
you know the platform you know layer
make it very interesting and we extend
it to the partner of service partners as
well as any users you know through
appliance to truly neighbor those
scenarios while we comply you know
where's the the policies and regulations
okay so who is that also let me show the
right place for second so you have to be
talked a lot about you or the platforms
the technologies and an even in a
similar policy stuff we're in a paradigm
shift when we have seen okay so so i'm
going to call couple of things this is
not if you know comprehensive or all
conclusive i'm sure there are a lot more
as we further into the cloud space and I
think this community in a will live a
lot and it will teach us along the way
as well but a few of them suddenly come
up i mean i think i'm going to talk
about to now really sitting long
scalability and elasticity okay so i
think you know we're moving away from a
traditional manager one server or couple
server you know kind of a paradigm to
managing thousands of server tens of
thousands of a server so the capability
of managing their large quantity of
infrastructure is huge and all the
students we will have failures and
outerwear to do with fears in the most
renault responsive kind of way and in
addition to the server management what
are other things about the pay attention
to in terms of its usage patterns
reasons performance in terms of are the
connections to utilization and
electricity to the space etc innocently
how
there is a globally distributed network
you know of those data centers those out
there a very important you know aspect
of scalable and you know the flexibility
you know what's important is really
bring the management are you no
requirement to the next level or in
terms of dealing with this massive
amount of you know infrastructures and
the second thing so also you know
continue on with the scalability is that
for application perspective there's a
lot of needs in terms of I will be able
to increase or decrease the resource are
you know based on the needs based on the
demand okay so how do you actually need
from the language perspective
architecture perspective a much easier
way of you know quickly scale up and
scale down your applications not only at
the instance level but also are in the
form of databases okay now in addition
to that there's a whole bunch of
appointing in terms of the state re
actually manages start of the state
estate synchronizations and a management
state cross this instance and also
really kind of rely on the cues and
providing the crews for the arg you know
the work that amount of worker roles now
all those are really the new set of
requirement for those application and
infrastructure in a warrior recall
computing in terms of being able
elasticity in label you know the skill
now in addition to that there's another
keyword a lot of people start talking
about riddle about military an embassy
okay so this is a part of that you know
if you use in terms of a hey how do I
really reduce the course by Jamie
multiple users in similar instance okay
now they are certain requirement in
terms of the data partitioning and a
synchronization becomes really a key but
even really importantly you know in that
kind of a paradigm how do we ensure the
tenant isolation to making sure their
security and also minimize the bit you
Parker there's a venomous things that
you know in the scientific community in
our work on hpc a little bit and
similarly getting a bit more exposure in
a scientific computing and if suddenly
from a dealing is a massive sort of a
data intensive you know calculation the
scientific community is actually moving
ahead along with all the new computation
you know powers in really the key
challenge is we actually dealing with is
that for the set of real funded a large
research organization no problem I am
doing my computing powers data centers
what a view you know terrain runs
through all my researchers but for
individual researchers or four small
bins of the organization has doesn't
have that luxury so we'll be really kind
of deformity is either leverage some of
the commodity clusters or you know
reducing the size of you know
researchers so as we started thinking
about cloud computing as we thinking
about this set of play as you go you
know the low interim point get into you
know those infrastructure usage is this
really a new opportunity for us to sort
of a Democrat Democrat izing the
researchers enable the small research
you know facility to able to leverage or
use the true you know computing powers
as a large research organization can
enjoy now as we look into this further I
have to say that and we haven't really
this is stupid and
unexplored area and whenever key you
know challenges really as we're thinking
about scientific application it has set
of unique characteristics and as we
looking evaluating course to call
computing platforms including my
personal hair and clothing as well as
Amazon's and etc when we designed this
platform is not necessary with
scientific computing in mind as we
dissolve with designer beautiful
long-running web services you know we
said of a moderate you know intro
connectivity or entering action or you
know among the amount of houston's
however the scientific computing is
actually have a wide range coming from a
CPU intensive sort of a you know set of
a calculation that doesn't require an
action two or three dynamics if you live
in fruitful in our analysis actually
require tons of you know imagine so this
in capture you know why range of
application types and it blossoms to be
allowed to really explain what glossy is
I think this is a the audience's very
familiar with what you know what that is
you know Phil volume 4 matrix research
and this is really a you know it will
commonly used the tool where she looking
at this war and say hey how do we take
in that example it does reflect some of
the classic scientific research problems
it is computationally intensive it is
very critical for biometrics are you
know what it also embodies all the
characteristics or most of the
characteristics a scientific computing
will represent so in that space we
actually did quite a bit of work or to
hear the as your boss that is sort of a
pail and
you know completely leveraging you know
Windows Azure platform and we took on
the architecture design that really
leverage the queue are you know
segmentation and also massive data
parallelism to being able to set of
scenarios to really try to test out the
performance and also the characteristics
of the Azrael platform you know in that
setting so here's some of the details
are you know if you're interested on the
more architecture or stuff that we can't
do that he'll fly but usually the
detailed limiter will have gone through
literally this is you know we're using a
worldwide completing powers from you
know microsoft's you know various data
centers are the thousands of instance
you know there have been deployed to
really analyze and an Dewey in a whole
dance or experiment you know of all the
sequences and then if we do that on a
single machine i think the estimation is
about you know six over years and in
this particular setup you know we did
that in about six to eight days there
was also some other numbers that have
been you know tossing alliances have
given you know if you're having a you
know 5,000 new porting strings and if
you want to do a reference check and in
comparison with reference database you
know again in the in the traditional
manner it's a hours and days and in this
particular setup it took us about you
know 30 minutes and initially there some
members and a five-song important
against five thousand you know different
stream and this is about thirty second
you know computation it does actually
are you know pray in a great amount of
efficiency enters of computing great
amount efficiency or in terms of brain
the actual research result more timely
to the marketplace so this is the native
example i was actually done by a local
team are there's a group of people
sitting in this room i'm sure they are
more than happy to you know spend some
time with you and
tell you all about you know they
experience terms of the original I'll
see you sitting at the back Santa Rosa
hair okay so people knows who you are so
talk to this gentleman if you want to
know more about Sigma so civilized
really are machine learning are you know
set of algorithms of men of the things
that what's interesting is that if you
think a manager you know as you a
platform they taking an example you know
it as always working on spc space
whether the example that we are trying
to figure out is there's a large amount
of financial data existing first of the
u.s. we actually did some study taking
the last ten years of us financial data
across a thousand banks okay so there's
all public available data and rid of the
things that far application for the
researcher perspectives saying that
instead of having me to touch those raw
data on their existing models that is
available that already shared about
research communities and etc I can build
on top of that so very similar to this I
mean there's a large number of you know
machine learning algorithms and a models
that is available today and how do I
tree using a call computing platform to
making those set of models a lot easily
shared across the community allow
communities to actually innovate on top
of those things we're adding you know
new models into those so there's our
fear you know examples if you're looking
at as your glass is all about you know
the scalability the relevancy along you
know the scientific communities and also
the new set of application design
architectural requires you know to use
the call platform and infer that you
know Sigma is really how do we bring
those models of predefined models of
morally argue no to the community allow
the new gem
innovation on top of that so the key
thing is really this is court reaction
over here you know we're excited and I
think this is a great for one or two
getting fun of all the top of mine in
the academic space to move this in
framework okay to move this info is a
lot of our partner will continuously
learning new tricks are you know in a
call computing space and we have some
learnings we want to share as well as we
running from the community some of the
key ones is really about how do we get
together actually really understand some
of the technical architectural
challenges that call conveniently left
on the table to really partners through
Microsoft researchers through Microsoft
in general or you know two are taking a
further steps are making this single
real and the ciliary teach distributed
and a scale programming classes in your
in your classrooms this is actually
something was very interesting in the i
think in us deserve a star is starting
to call computing coursework and in the
china i know they a few university also
start working to our you know course
where are in terms of driving call
computing capabilities are in a new
generation of counsel students in the
city of beauty onion clouds a partner
was you know microsoft in terms of you
know getting their hands on experience I
mean I think the Adria brasa is a great
experiment in a force not only in our
set of its cool we're also really
learning a lot of nitty gritty details
in terms of what the plan brings will
some of the key challenge this profit
represent you know what that powerful
good are good on what's not so good at
and other we continuously increase that
but I think come join this community are
and a really focusing your energy of the
space that you're super super you know
good our expertise that and then partner
with Microsoft to making sure that we
have
actual a meaningful users of call
computing we're not talking about
concepts we're not talking about
definitions who are talking about actual
implementation we're talking about your
usage to bring the set of services to
the broader audience it was that I think
I managed Tyrese them they arrived 10
minutes are for some questions
right I'm from clan university so i have
a question right now as you is just as a
platform as a service right so in the
future if you are planning for microsoft
to extenders are due to the software as
a service what it mean you know right
now maybe a song that they talk about in
the future we don't need a operating
system in the computer we just only a
maybe you need a process something like
this all the software may be just
installed on the server so is there any
plan for Microsoft to use zoom to as
software-as-a-service not just any other
platform Thank you Thank You things for
that question I mean the question of
Allah it original microsoft is actually
extending as you're going to become a
sort of a software-as-a-service and you
know bunch of do a set of sulfurous
services okay so there's our uniform of
our office line of products in terms of
productivity you think about a windows
into in terms of set of online services
for desktop management and mercenary
Dynamics CRM s are so we're actually you
know have a set of commercial usage of
software-as-a-service are many of them
will be my bolero start building on top
of the you know as your problems or form
a company perspective in a we do offer
things not only at the platform as a
service layer but also in also for the
service level recently looking forward
to our enable mass majority of Sir party
vendors to bring additional software as
a service you know on top of that
platform okay so that's sitting as a
planet we already have you know in
deployment are you know for the last
year you know you also and this um you
know could take you know on those it is
gentle over there or over here
I come from behind risky so I'm quite
agree on one of the suggestion that we
should promote education for the
programmers to write the scale out
applications or programs so here I'd
like to ask you a question is that in
your painting the key different of the
say programming language or programming
for the cloud platform such as or when
compared with C or C++ language and the
the second question is more related to
one talk this morning say if we want to
change train the student too familiar
with such kind of a new programming
model so commonly speaking we should
give them a platform and they can try
and universal update something on the
platform trip so what do you think about
how to promote this kind of training or
education in universities ok thank you
personal questions I mean this is
actually my team is a quite a bit for
sale in places like China also many
observers really to question their one
is from the application